The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Then let
me just-- I gave you
two things about
the last class, one
is the question about the
electron and factors of 2
and what precesses
at what frequency.
Think about it, I mean,
write down for yourself
what is a magnetic
moment of an electron?
What is a magnetic moment of
a classical particles which
is one unit of angular
momentum and try to sort of re
derive it.
The way how I did it
is deceptively simple.
But whenever you
think about it, you
will get confused
about some factors.
But this is, of course,
where I showed you here
is the quantum mechanical
mystery about the g-factor of 2
that you have an electron
which has one more
magneton of magnetic moment, and
you have a classical particle
which has one more magneton.
The energy levels of up
and down what are the same.
The energy is 1.4
megahertz per Gauss.
But the precession of
frequency of the electron
is 2 times faster than
the precession frequency
of the classical
particle, and this
is what the g-factor of 2, which
comes out of the Dirac equation
means.
And at least one
intuitive explanation
I can give you is a
frequency which is observed
as a precession frequency
in the laboratory
is the beat frequency between
two neighboring levels.
And here you have
a level in between.
So the beat frequency between
two neighboring levels
is 1.4 megahertz, and
here the beat frequency
is 2.8 megahertz.
And you will actually
see that if you
take a classic system
which has much,
much larger angular
momentum, maybe L equals 10.
It will have this
level structure,
but it will go from
minus 10 to plus 10.
But the precession frequency
is the beat frequency
between two levels.
Or if you don't like
the word beat frequency,
it precesses and you can
increase the precession.
So if you're not
increasing the impression,
you can increase the energy
of the precessing system
by driving it at the
resonance frequency which
is a precession frequency.
And the resonance is always
the energy difference
between two levels.
So no matter how many levels
you have in a classical system
with a g-factor of 1, you're
always driving it step by step,
and each step is the
resonance and this
is the precession
frequency of the system.
Questions about it?
I know people get
confused all the time,
but just think about it.
I think I gave you all
the different angles
you can use to look at it.
Questions about that?
OK.
Next thing I just want
to point out is rotation.
Yes, we are spending
quite some time in class
just to figure out that
something is rotating.
So what we figured out
here is that if you
go to a rotating frame, if
you have angular momentum,
and we go to a rotating
frame, that that simply
means that the effect
of a rotating frame
is to simply add a
fictitious magnetic fields
to the real magnetic field.
Well, that's very handy.
For instance, we
know then immediately
if you have a real
magnetic field
and we pick the
fictitious magnetic field
in such a way that the
real magnetic field
that the total field cancels it.
It cancels the total
magnetic field, well,
then we have a system viewed
from the rotating frame
where the effective field is 0.
Well, the spin is zero
field does nothing
and then we know when you
go back into the lab frame,
all this spin is
doing it rotates.
It's an exact solution.
I want to use it today again
but in a different way,
but I want to just
point out today
we will not picking the
fictitious field to make
the magnetic field zero.
Today we are talking
about what happens
to a spin in a rotating field.
Complicated.
A time-dependent problem,
time-dependent Hamiltonian.
But if you go in a rotating
frame, if you rotate
with the field, then
in the rotating frame
it becomes a
time-independent problem
which we can immediately solve.
So today we use the same
transformation again,
but we pick our frequency not
to cancel some static field.
We pick our frequency
to co-rotate
with an external rotating field
that in our rotating frame now
everything is stationary.
So that's what you're
going to do today.
And finally just to
give you an outlook,
just try to sort of make you
aware that often what we're
doing is the same thing
in a different angle.
So this is one way to
deal with rotation.
I'll give you an exact solution
by going to rotating frame.
I will later show you today
that quantum mechanically
the solution to the Heisenberg
equation of motion for angular
momentum or magnetic
moment in a magnetic field
is exactly a rotation.
So we'll again show you that
a quantum mechanical solution,
the solution of a time-dependent
problem is exactly rotation.
And later on when we use the
spin-1/2 Hamiltonian and we
write down the wave function,
we solve sometimes the wave
function by transforming
the wave function.
And this will be, again, the
rotating frame transformation.
It's not always called like
this, but it's always the same.
You go to some form
of rotating frame,
and we'll do that in
three different ways.
This is the first way just as
a general classical physics
transformation to
rotating frame.
We will do it again
for the expectation
value as a solution of
Heisenberg's equation
of motion, and
then we do it again
when we transform
the wave function
with a unitary transformation.
A lot of time for simple
rotations, but its good thing.
It really provides
a lot of insight.
Anyway, this is more sort of
an outlook over today's lecture
and part of Tuesday's lecture.
Any question about the
summary and the outlook?
Because before I really come
back to the rotating frame,
I quickly want to do
something I couldn't.
I ran out of time on Monday.
We talked so much about harmonic
oscillators, the precision
at which we can
determine the frequency
of the harmonic
oscillator, and I really
want to give you examples.
I want give you two outstanding
examples for atomic clocks.
And the two extreme
examples are, well,
the two best atomic
clocks in the world.
One is the cesium atom
with a fountain clock.
Well, we'll talk about
it later, but some of you
know that the cesium atom
is hyper fine structure.
In one state, the electron
and nucleus spin are parallel.
In the other state,
they are antiparallel,
and the transition frequency
is 10 gigahertz, well,
9.something, but for the
matter of this discussion,
it's 10 gigahertz.
And the definition of time,
the definition for 1 second
is in terms of so-and-so many
cycles of this transition.
So this transition
has this frequency,
and for decades,
this frequency was
determined in an atomic beam.
You have an atomic cesium
beam, and you interrogate it
with microwave fields.
But now with cold atoms, we
can achieve much, much longer
interrogation times by
almost completely eliminating
the atomic motion.
In the current
experiment, is that you
have a cloud
[? lace ?] are cooled
to micro Kelvin temperature.
You launch it into a fountain.
The cloud goes up and goes down,
and you interrogate it twice
and the interrogation
time is 1 second.
And this interrogation time is
no longer as in the convention
atomic clocks limited by the
thermal velocity of the atom,
it's limited by gravity.
If you want to increase
a time to 10 seconds,
you need a 100-meter tower and
nobody wants to build that.
I mean, it would be a
really big atomic clock.
So therefore you usually deal
with an interrogation time
on the order of 1 second.
So we know that based
on Fourier's theorem,
delta is a factor of 2
pi, but the line widths,
if you would recall
now the spectrum,
the line widths, delta omega,
would be that's a factor of 2,
but it would be 1 over 1 second.
And therefore the fractional
accuracy is 10 to the 11,
is on the order of
10 to the minus 11.
However, the accuracy of
the base cesium fountains
is now 10 to the minus 16.
So people are able to split
the line to 1 part in 100,000,
which requires
exquisite knowledge,
exquisite knowledge
of the line shape
and also systematic effects,
but well, an atomic clock
is a piece of art.
And I just want to
emphasize that I sometimes
feel when I talk about the
uncertainty at which you can
measure a classical oscillator
or such is almost trivial,
and you should
know all about it.
But I can just say without
looking at anybody that I just
had a lunch discussion with
some of my graduate student
and we talked about
laser stabilization.
And one graduate student asked,
but if the natural line widths
of a transition is 10 megahertz,
can we stabilized a laser
to better than a megahertz?
Of course, we can.
I mean, here we have a
natural line width of 10
to the minus 11, but we
can get an a accuracy
of a signal, which is
10 to the minus 16.
So a microwave oscillator,
which is the microwave accrual
end of a laser can now be
locked to the cesium transition
with a precision of
10 to the minus 16,
100,000 times better
than the line width.
Let me give you
a second example.
Just noticing the red color.
This is red.
I wanted to highlight it.
There's probably
nothing we can do.
It seems the projector
is not showing the color.
Well, in the lecture
post, the lecture notes,
this will be bright
red, but maybe I
should use more blue
and green and yellow
for highlighting it today.
That's really odd.
Yellow-- OK.
The red is completely missing.
The other example I want to give
you is the strontium-- yeah,
it's blue-- the
strontium optical clock.
And there was a
really nice paper
in Nature just a few
weeks ago, and well, here
is a level diagram
of atomic strontium
what happens is there is
a very fast transition s
to p transition for laser
cooling and trapping
and all that, but then there
is a very, very slow transition
[? forbidden ?] to a triplet
state, which is meta stable.
And this transition,
those states
have a very long lifetime,
and therefore this transition
is extremely level.
So what is state of the art
for the strontium clock?
Well, in the experiment, they
use an interrogation time.
So they observe the
atom for delta t, which
is on the order of
160 milliseconds
and putting in the 2 pis in
the right place that would mean
the frequency
resolution is 1 Hertz.
And you see that on
the left-hand side when
we record the resonance, the
blue one is about 1 Hertz
and there is something broader.
This is when they
are not actively
feeding back the magnetic field.
So for this fantastic position,
you have to control everything,
but the blue line
is sort of what
we record as a clock transition.
It's about 1 Hertz.
Now, compared to a cesium
clock, the big advantage
is that the strontium clock
operates in the optical domain,
and this is a frequency at
5 times 10 to the 14 Hertz.
So we're seeing if the
frequency is much, much
faster even if you have a
shorter interrogation time,
your relative
accuracy is better.
And here the Q value
the mu over delta mu
is on the order of 10
times 10 to the minus 15.
Fantastic.
15 orders of magnitude, and they
are splitting the line, not as
extreme as the cesium atomic
clock by a factor of 100,000,
by a factor which is
on the order of 300.
And with that, they have an
accuracy, which is now really
the record for the
base performance
of any atomic clock, which is
6 times 10 to the minus 18.
Now, this is now in
the optical domain.
You may wonder about the
laser, how stable is the laser.
The laser is stabilized
to an optical activity,
but the laser because of
thermal fluctuations, not
terminal fluctuations,
thermal fluctuations
in the mirror because
of thermal noise
is limited in the short
term to 10 to the minus 16.
So the short term stability
between 1 and 1,000
second is 10 to the minus 16.
So they use a laser which
has a stability of 10
to the minus 16.
Every 1.3 seconds,
they take a data point.
Each data point or
the spectral widths
is 2 times 10 to the--
the laser is 10 to the 16.
The line we record
is 10 to the 15,
but seen since the thermal
noise is completely random
and by averaging it, they
can determine the line center
to better than 10 to the 17.
So I think this just illustrates
the precision at the which
you can observe the
harmonic oscillator,
and what I like
about this example,
it shows you that both the
transition you are recording
and the laser itself-- 10
to the 15, 10 to the 16--
are worse than the final
precision of the measurement,
which is better
than 10 to the 17.
Make sense, but yes,
that's what it is.
Questions about that?
Yes, Collin.
AUDIENCE: What was the accuracy
of the [INAUDIBLE] result?
Was it better than 6
times 10 to the minus 18?
PROFESSOR: No.
This 6 times 10 to
the minus 18 is really
the [INAUDIBLE] record.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
[? atomic ?] clock?
PROFESSOR: There was an
aluminum ion clock, which had,
I think, 10 the
minus 17 precision.
But I think it's 6 times 10 to
the minus 18 is close to that.
So they are close or
they are better now
than the aluminum clock, but the
aluminum clock is a single ion.
You have to ever reach
for much, much longer time
to get this precision.
So that's a big advantage for
the strontium clock, which
is many, many atoms
in an optical lattice,
and they say that they
have improved on the best
previous lattice clock
by a factor of 20.
But I think the
improvement effect of 20,
you always have to distinguish
between sensitivity
and absolute precision.
In the absolute
precision, you also
have to control all
systematic effects.
And the big step
here which was really
boosting the absolute
precision was they completely
controlled the black
body environment.
So you really have to know
with high precision what
is the effective temperature
of the black body radiation
because at the 10 to
the minus 18 level,
it causes a shift of
the atomic resonance.
We talk later about it, but
it's the ac Stark effect
of the black body
radiation, which
becomes an important systematic
at that level of precision.
I don't know exactly the number
of the previous atomic clocks,
but this is sort of
now the gold standard
of frequency methodology.
OK.
Let's go.
Yes, what you have
here is you have
sort of classical
harmonic oscillator,
but the classical
harmonic oscillator
is based on doing measurements
on seamless strontium
atoms and single cesium atoms.
So you see that the accuracy,
and we had a discussion on it
last class, the accuracy
at which you can observe
a quantum mechanical oscillator.
In a classical oscillator,
it's pretty much the same.
It's the same kind of-- if you
have a good signal to noise,
you can improve your
precision for the line center
substantially.
From those results, and
exciting atomic clocks,
let's go back to
classical physics.
So we want to go back to our
classical magnetic moment
and understand the motion of it.
But in addition to what
we discussed so far,
a stationary magnetic
field, we now
want to add to it a
rotating magnetic field.
So the situation
is that-- just use
another color-- we
have a magnetic moment.
We assume it's classical,
and we have a magnetic field,
which we assume points
along the z-axis.
And then, of
course, we know that
from our previous
discussion that the spin
undergoes precession.
It's sort of precesses
around the magnetic field
at the Larmor frequency.
And now, let's assume we
have-- the yellow shows up.
We have a rotating field.
We add a rotating
field eight B1,
and just to keep
things simple, we
want to assume that the
rotating field rotates
at the same frequency
as a magnetic moment,
so we are on a resonance.
Because what happens
now is we can simply
do a transformation
to the rotating frame.
The rotating frame is now
at the Larmor frequency
and we have just learned that in
the rotating frame, of course,
in the rotating frame the
rotating field stands still,
so it becomes a
static field which
points in the x direction.
And we have the static
field in the z direction,
but now that's what
I just reviewed.
We have a fictitious
magnetic field,
which comes from the
transformation to the rotating
frame and on resonance,
at the Larmor frequency,
this is exactly the
negative of B naught.
So in other words,
we started out
to expose a magnetic moment
to a time-dependent field.
So we had a rotating field
cosine omega Lt sine omega Lt.
But in the rotating frame,
this becomes now the x prime x,
and it's stationary
in the rotating frame.
So this was the field
in the lab frame.
In the rotating frame, we
have an effective field,
which is the field
in the lab frame
minus the fictitious field,
and the fictitious field
was given by that.
It just cancels the
B naught component.
And in the rotating frame,
this vector and this vector
cancels and we are just left
with a field of strengths
B1, which points in
the x-axis, or actually
the x-axis in the rotating
frame is what I call x prime.
So therefore, we have
a very simple problem
that in the rotating frame.
We have a static
field of value B1.
And the good thing is,
we know already what
a magnetic moment does
with a static field.
The magnetic moment
is just precessing
around the static
magnetic field.
So therefore, our
solution is now
we have transformed the
time-dependent field
and now we know that mu
precesses around this field,
and the precession frequency
is the Rabi frequency, which
we discussed previously.
The Rabi frequency is the
gyromagnetic ratio times B1.
So therefore, if
we would start out
with a magnetic moment
aligned with the z-axis.
If we would wait
half a Rabi's cycle,
the magnetic moment
would now be inverted.
So the situation is we have
a magnetic moment which
points in the z-axis with
a field in the z-axis.
But we expose it
to a rotating field
which rotates in the xy plane.
So in the rotating frame,
we have a stationary field
which points in x.
In this rotating frame,
the spin is simply
precessing around what
is now a steady field,
and after half a Ravi
cycle, the spin points down.
So therefore we know--
going back to lab frame--
that this rotating field has
caused in quantum mechanics
I would say a spin
flip, a full reversal
of the magnetic
moment, and this is
what we call the pi
pulse-- it has already
rotated the spin by pi--
or we call it a spin flip,
but it's a completely
classical system.
Any questions?
Well, then I would
question for you.
I've discussed with you the case
that the rotating field rotates
at the Larmor frequency.
But now I want to discuss the
case that the rotating field is
not at the Larmor
frequency, it's
at the frequency omega
1, which is faster
than the Larmor frequency.
And the question
is now what will
happen to the spin or
the magnetic moment.
I explained to you
that on a resonance,
the magnetic moment was
just flipping over, rotating
precessing at the
Rabi frequency.
And I want you to think
about it for a moment
and then decide if
we go off resonant,
if we drive this system
away from the resonance
with a rotating field which
is faster than the Larmor
frequency, what is
now the oscillation
frequency of the
magnetic moment.
And so the choices are, is it
larger, smaller, or the same?
And this was, of course,
compared to the Rabi frequency.
So I've explained to you
that the spin flip, the Rabi
flopping, or the pi
pulse-- and this picture
was at the magnetic moment--
does Rabi flopping rotates
plus z minus, z plus, z minus,
z at the Rabi frequency.
But now we drive
the system faster
than the Larmor frequency
and the question
is, is whatever this
magnetic moment does,
is it faster, slower,
or does it always
happen at the Rabi frequency?
Larger.
Good.
Well, let me then immediately
add another twist.
What would happen-- let's
ask the same question,
but now we are driving
it at a lower frequency.
The yellow.
This projector has a problem.
So now same question
as before, but instead
of driving the system with a
faster rotating field, faster
than the Larmor frequency,
we are driving it
with a smaller frequency.
Is now the response of
the magnetic moment,
the effective precession
frequency, larger, smaller,
or the same as the Rabi
frequency as the resonant case?
OK, good.
So that means I can go very
quickly about the explanation.
It's correct.
Whenever you are off
resonant, this system
precesses faster,
so let me summarize
what probably is
obvious to all of you.
What happens when we have an
off-resonant rotating field.
When we have an
off-resonant rotating field,
we go to the rotating frame, but
of course, the rotating frame
we go to is now not rotating
at the Larmor frequency
because the purpose of
going to rotating frame
is get rid of the time
dependence of the rotating
field.
So we go to rotating
frame which rotates
at the frequency of
the rotating field.
So if the rotating field
rotates at a frequency omega,
we have a fictitious field,
which is omega over gamma.
Gamma is the gyromagnetic ratio.
For the resonant case, we
were just completely canceling
the static field
in the z direction,
but for the
off-resonant case, when
omega is larger or
smaller in both cases,
this one here is no longer 0.
And our total
effective field is now
the quadrature sum of what
we have in the z direction,
and what we have in the x
direction or x prime direction,
this is B1.
So in the z direction,
we have the static field
minus the fictitious field
and then the two are added up
On resonance, the angle
theta is 90 degrees,
but for the off-resonant
case, the angle
is different given by the
simple geometric result.
And the effective field is the
quadrature sum of B1 squared
plus B naught
minus-- and the fact
is this adds something to the
effective field in the rotating
frame whether we drive it
above or below resonance.
So therefore the
magnetic moment precesses
at what is called
the generalized Rabi
frequency, which I now call--
this would be red-- let's use
green instead-- the generalized
Rabi frequency, which
is gamma times B
effective, and this
is the quadrature
sum of the detuning
plus the capital
letter omega, omega R,
is the Rabi frequency
at resonance,
and this is nothing else
than a measure for the drive
field for the strengths of the
drive field B1 in frequencies.
So therefore, the
generalized Rabi frequency
is the resonant Rabi
frequency added in quadrature
with the detuning squared.
Any questions?
So because it's an exact result
and I like the result Rabi
flopping at the
generalized Rabi frequency,
I want to derive it for you.
So I want to figure out what
is the dynamic of a spin which
is originally
aligned, and now it
undergoes-- it is driven
by the rotating field.
Remember, the resonant
case was very simple.
The spin was just
doing Rabi flopping.
It was fully inverted,
came back, and just
did this at that Rabi frequency.
Now we know that in
the off-resonant case,
there will be an
effective magnetic field
and it will precess at a
faster frequency, which
is a generalized
Rabi frequency, but
since the effective magnetic
field is not transverse,
it has a z component, the
spin will never fully invert.
So geometrically,
it's very easy.
We start out with a magnetic
moment at zero time,
and I can immediately draw
to you the complete solution.
The complete solution is that
in the rotating frame, this sort
of precesses around the
effective magnetic field.
This is the solution.
But I just wanted to do
is because it takes me
three or four minutes, I
want to read from this graph,
from this drawing, one of
two trigonometric identities
and derive for you the
explicit expression,
what is the value of
the magnetic moment
as a function of time.
But it's clear from that it
will have a maximum value.
It precesses around
the tilt direction,
and when it's over there,
it has a minimum value,
but it will never
completely invert.
Well, quantum mechanically,
if you drive a system not
on resonance, you
cannot completely invert
the population, but
we'll come to the later.
So what do I need?
Well, the spin is
moving here on a circle.
I need a few angles.
So let's say the spin
was here at one time.
At another time, it
is there, and that
would mean that on the circle,
it has moved an angle phi.
The tilt angle between the
spin and the magnetic field
is what I call theta.
And the angle between the
initial magnetic moment
and the magnetic moment at
time, t, is what I call alpha.
Yeah, these other the
three relevant angles.
The tip of the magnetic
moment goes in a circle,
and this circle has a radius,
which is mu times sine theta.
Sine theta is nothing else than
the rotating magnetic field
over the effective
magnetic field, which
is nothing else than the
resonant Rabi frequency divided
by the generalized
Rabi frequency.
I said what I want
to determinant
is the magnetic moment in
the z direction as a function
of time, and for that, I
defined the angle cosine alpha.
So the way how I derive it
the easiest way, its geometry,
its three dimension, and
triangles, and all that.
But the best way how I
can describe it for you,
let me introduce this auxiliary
line, which connects the tip
of the magnetic moment at
time t equals 0 and at time t.
And I call the length
of this line A.
And I want to derive-- I want
to have now two triangles where
one side is A, determine
A in two different ways,
combine the equation,
we are done.
So the first way is that
we have the magnetic moment
at time 0, the magnetic
moment at time, t.
We said the angle is
alpha, and the two tips
are connected by A, and you know
in every triangle you have this
would Pythagoras, but
in the general case,
this is valid for
general triangle.
So applying that to this
triangle, we have a square.
b square is mu square.
c square is mu square,
so we get 2 mu square.
And then this term 2 ab is 2
mu times mu times cosine alpha,
so therefore, this is
1 minus cosine alpha.
So we've taken care
of the first triangle.
I hope the drawing is
not completely confusing
at this point, but
why don't we just
look at the drawing looking
down the effective field.
We look down at
the effective field
and then we see the circle where
the magnetic moment precesses,
and the radius of the circle
I've already given to you.
So now we want to look down
the effective magnetic moment.
We see the circle.
We want to lock down the
effective magnetic field.
We see the circular where the
magnetic moment precesses.
It's has precessed
form here to there.
We connect this line.
This was our A, and the angle
at which the magnetic moment
has precesses is phi.
And the radius as we derived
before was mu times sine theta.
So now just using the same
equation for this triangle,
we find that A square is 2
mu square sine square theta
times 1 minus cosine phi.
And for cosine phi, I want
to use the trig identity
and express it by
half the angle.
All right, now we are done.
We're pretty much
looking at this--
the drawing is clear
precession around a tilt angle,
and we're just
doing geometry here.
And we have now two
expressions for A square.
We can set the two
expression equal
and solve for the unknown,
which is cosine over [? phi. ?]
And with that, we
find the cosine alpha
is 1 minus 2 sine square
theta sine square phi over 2.
And the purpose of this exercise
was that cosine alpha tells us
the tilt angle of the
magnetic moment away form
the vertical axis,
so therefore, we
have done what we wanted to do.
We know the z component
of the magnetic moment
as a function of
time is this times 1
minus generalized Rabi frequency
squared times sine square.
And now we know the precession
phi, the precession at which
the keep of the magnetic
moment moves in a circle,
we discussed it already before,
and you gave the correct answer
with the clicker,
is this generalized
Rabi frequency omega Rabi.
So that's a nice formula, but
before we lean back and look
at it, let me just
do one tiny step.
Based on our quantum
mechanical background,
we can now define that the
probability that the spin has
been flipped is the
relative difference
in the z component
appropriately normalized.
This is just the normalized
change in the z component,
and if I call that
the probability that,
that which is on
the left-hand side,
then I find that the probability
for this classically expression
for which expresses how much
the z component of the magnetic
moment has changed, and this is
exactly the celebrated formula
for spin flips in
a spin-1/2 system.
So we have derived
exactly the solution
for the motion for the
precession of a magnetic moment
in a magnetic field plus
the rotating magnetic field,
and what we found is, we
found that the magnetic moment
precesses at the
generalized Rabi frequency.
And as I will show
you next week,
this result is
exactly the same as
for quantum mechanical
expectation values.
Question, yeah?
AUDIENCE: So what if we have
magnetic field oscillating just
in one direction instead of
rotation magnetic fields?
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's a much
more complicated problem.
What happens when we have
the magnetic field which
is linearly polarized,
which is only
oscillating in one direction?
Well, light or a vector
which is oscillating linearly
in one direction can be
regarded as a superposition
of a left and right
rotating field.
In other words, if you
superimpose left-handed
and right-handed
circular polarized light,
the sum of the two is
linearly polarized light.
So now we have
actually the situation
that linearly polarized
magnetic field-- that's
what we usually do when the lab.
I mean, we have coils.
We connect them to
synthesizer and the field
is not going in a circle.
It's going back and forth.
It's linearly polarized.
This corresponds
to a magnetic field
which corresponds to
two magnetic field, one
rotates left and
one rotates right.
But the problem is if you
now do a transformation
in the rotating
frame, do we want
to rotate omega to the
left or omega to the right?
So what we can do is, we
can pick our rotating frame
and we are now in
the rotating frame.
One of the rotating fields
has become time independent,
the other rotates
now at 2 omega.
And at that point, we need
the celebrated rotating wave
approximation that we keep the
one term [? via ?] rectified
and the other one
at two omega rotates
so rapidly that we say these
rapid oscillations do nothing
and we discard it.
We'll discussed it
later in this course.
But the gist is, if you
have linearly-polarized
light, linearly-polarized
magnetic fields,
we usually have to do an
additional approximation,
the rotating wave approximation.
And since the rotating wave
approximation is done always
in almost any treatment,
any paper you can find,
we think it's always necessary.
But what I've shown to you is,
when we have a rotating field,
we don't need any approximation.
The transformation in the
rotating frame is exact,
but that's the beauty of it the
when we assume rotating frames,
we can hold on to exact
solutions for longer and only
later then discuss what
happens when we introduce
linearly-polarized
magnetic fields.
But that's something
we definitely
do later in its full beauty.
15 minutes.
OK.
There's one thing I want
to do about classical spins
and then we do with the
full quantum treatment.
And this aspect
of classical spins
is called rapid
adiabatic passage.
So we want to add one more
piece to our discussion.
So far we have assumed a static
field and a rotating field,
which rotates at one frequency.
But now we want to change
the frequency of the rotating
field.
So we have our magnetic moment
in a static magnetic field,
which is our quantization axis.
And now we have
a rotating field,
but we increase the frequency
of the rotating field from slow
to fast and ask what happens.
And the result is that by
increasing the frequency,
sweeping the frequency
through the resonance,
we can do something very useful.
We can invert the spin.
We can turn over the magnetic
moment in a very robust way,
and this is the concept of
rapid adiabatic passage.
A lot of you may be
familiar with the concept
a Landau-Zener
transition, what I'm
telling you what is exactly
the classical counterpart
of the Landau-Zener transition.
actually in many cases when
it comes to spin physics,
the classical physics and the
quantum physics is the same.
So that's why I want to
discuss rapid adiabatic passage
and Landau-Zener physics first
in the classical environment.
So rapid adiabatic
passage is a technique
for inverting turning around
spins or magnetic moments
by sweeping the frequency
of your drive field
across the resonance.
So adiabatic means that this
frequency sweep has to be slow.
Slow is slow compared
to the Larmor frequency.
We get any given moment the
magnetic moment precesses
at the Larmor frequency, which
is the gyromagnetic ratio
times g-factor
magnetic field, so it's
sort of quasi stationary.
The spin precesses around
the effective magnetic field
and we want to change the
frequency of the drive
slow compared to that motion.
Well, the word rapid
adiabatic passage
has the word adiabatic, which
means slow but also rapid.
The word rapid means
we have to be rapid
compared to relaxation
processes, which we do not
discuss here in an
idealized environment.
For instance, if you do
rapid adiabatic passage
in the environment where
the atoms can collide,
rapid means you have to do it
fast enough before you have
decoherence in two collisions,
so slow compared to the Larmor
frequency and rapid
compared to all the things
I'm not mentioning
here-- rapid compared
to decoherence and
relaxation processes.
I will not set up differential
equation and solve them.
I want to give you the intuitive
picture of what goes on,
but then also
derive what is sort
of the criterion
for adiabadicity,
which we have to fulfill.
So what are our ingredients?
We have a magnetic moment, mu.
We have a static field B naught.
We have a drive field B1, which
rotates at a frequency omega.
And we assume that
the rotating field
is smaller than
the static field.
It's not absolutely
necessary, but you
apply a big static
field and then you
have a repetitive drive.
That's a standard situation.
Or we always want to have
quantization axis, which
is given with the
z-axis as defined
by the static magnetic
field, but it's only
defined by the
static magnetic field
if the transverse
field is not much
larger than the static
field, otherwise,
we are talking about a
somewhat different problem.
And let me just assume
to be specific we later
discuss what happens
if it's not the case.
We assume that we start with
a frequency omega, which
is much, much smaller
than the Larmor frequency,
much, much smaller
than the resonance.
So what does that mean for
our effective magnetic field?
Let me just sketch it for you.
Remember our effective
magnetic field,
we have a field B naught.
We have a drive field B1,
which we assume is smaller.
But then when we go
to the rotating frame,
we have a fictitious field,
but if the frequency omega
is below the Larmor frequency,
this fictitious field
is very small.
So therefore, we start
out in a situation
where the effective field
is pretty much pointing
along the z direction.
So just to remind you,
so we have a situation
where the effective field
is just at a tiny angle,
and if we started out with our
magnetic moment aligned in z,
and we assume B1 is really
perturbative, pretty
much the magnetic moment
is very tightly coupled.
It has a very small precession
angle, or if you want,
if you take the magnetic
field B1 to be perturbative,
you can say the
magnetic moment is
aligned with the
effective field.
That's the limit that the
cone angle of precession
is very small.
So let we write that down.
This is what's omega
much, much smaller
than the Larmor frequency.
So now we want to
turn up the knob
on the frequency of the drive.
We want to rotate the drive
field B1 faster and faster.
And the picture you should
have is-- I just wiped it away,
but what that means is,
the effective field,
the fictitious field is no
longer and longer component
and on resonance, the
fictitious magnetic field
will cancel B naught.
So in other words,
at this point,
when B naught is canceled,
the effective field
has only the B1 component
in the x direction.
So therefore, when be
go to delta equal 0,
the effective field is only B1
and points in the x direction.
So what we have done is
by changing the frequency,
by ramping up the
frequency to resonance,
we have tilted the
effective magnetic field
from the z direction
into the x direction.
And at any given
moment, I mean, we
know what the exact solution
of the magnetic moment is.
At any given moment,
the magnetic moment
precesses around the
effective magnetic field.
And if the precession
is very fast
and the effective magnetic
field is slowly rotating,
the magnetic moment
is just following.
So therefore, at this point
when we are at resonance,
we have tilted the magnetic
moment by 90 degrees.
Just one second.
And if we go with a
frequency much higher
than the Larmor frequency, then
our fictitious magnetic field
is much larger than B
naught and therefore,
the effective magnetic
field points now
in the minus z direction.
So the idea is that as
long as this rotation
of the effective field from
being plus z in the x direction
and into minus z is slow
enough, the rapid precession is
locking, is keeping the
magnetic moment aligned
with the effective
magnetic field
and we have just a
handle we invert.
We move around the
magnetic moment.
So in the adiabatic limit,
the spin precesses tightly,
and by tightly I mean the angle
theta is small around B ef, B
effective, and
follows the direction
of the effective magnetic field.
So we are rotating
an effective field.
We are rotating the
magnetic moment,
but we're not rotating
anything in the laboratory.
The only thing we
are doing is, we
are changing the frequency of
the rotating magnetic field.
Questions?
Jenny.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I was thinking, can
you also do this
by keeping the
frequency the same
and just ramping
up the strength?
Like say, put it at
the-- make the B1
equal to the frequency
of that Larmor frequency
and just start
from 0 and ramp up?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
I mean, the essence here is that
the effective magnetic field
is [INAUDIBLE] resonance,
and what you are suggesting
is if the frequency is
constant, that would
mean the fictitious
magnetic field is constant.
But if you were given a
fictitious magnetic field
and we a huge field B naught,
the effective magnetic field
points out, points up.
But if we now make this
static field B naught smaller
and smaller, both
through resonance
and make it even
smaller, we have also
done an inversion of the
effective magnetic field.
The result is the same.
Actually, sometimes
in the laboratory,
if you have a synthesizer
which is not easily
computer controlled,
we do an analog sweep
of the magnetic
field, so we actually
change the Larmor frequency
of the atom instead
of changing the drive frequency.
What really matters
in the whole business
is the relative frequency
between the two.
AUDIENCE: Is it necessarily
true that the spin resistance
is tightly around
the effective fields?
Isn't it at resonance the radius
of the circle in precession
is equal to mu?
Is it my [INAUDIBLE]
before we found
the radius which
was mu sine theta.
Then sine theta cosine Omega R--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --divided into--
PROFESSOR: But the
way is we start--
the way we've
started it up here.
Now if we are far
away from resonance,
the angle theta is
infinitesimally small.
Something confuses you.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, it's just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: See,
what we have solved
before, we have done
something else before.
What we have
discussed before is,
that we have a spin
which is aligned
and then we looked at the-- you
can say the transient solution,
we switched suddenly
on the rotating field.
So that may sort
of described that.
We have a magnetic field,
which is in the z direction.
Obviously we don't.
Our spin is aligned
in the z direction.
And if you then suddenly
switch on a rotating field,
that could mean
you have suddenly
created an effective
field, which is tilted.
So then by the sudden
switch on of your drive,
you have an angle theta and
the magnetic moment precesses
with the precession angle theta.
But what we are
here doing is, we
are ever so slightly
changing the angle theta
and then the spin stays aligned.
That's the difference.
So before I give
you another example
and discuss the limit
of adiabadicity,
let's just have a
quicker question
to make sure that
everybody follows.
So OK, what I think we
have at least understood
in the adiabatic
limit is, that when
we start with a magnetic
moment, which is aligned,
and now we do a sweep, we start
with a small rotating frequency
and we make it large.
We sweep from low to high
frequency through resonance,
then we can invert
the magnetic moment.
My question for you
now is, what happens
when we start with
a spin but we switch
on a drive, which
is a buff resonance
and we sweep it with
small frequencies?
What will now happen when
we do the opposite sweep?
Will the spin just stay,
will it be flipped,
or will it sort of get
diffused or get disoriented?
So this is answer A, this is
answer B, and this is answer C.
So what happens?
I have assumed in
already discussion
before that we start with
a very low frequency where
the fictitious magnetic
field is negligible.
And then we change
the frequency,
we sweep the frequency.
It cause the Larmor frequency
to very high frequency.
My question now is,
what happens when
we reverse the
frequency of the sweep?
OK.
There is some distribution.
The correct answer is
indeed B, we flip the spin.
What happens is the following.
The spin is in the z direction,
but at high frequency,
the fictitious magnetic
field is very large.
So therefore, the
effective magnetic field
is now a large
pointing in the
minus z direction.
So now we have a situation
where the spin tightly precesses
around the magnetic
effective magnetic field
at an angle of 180 degrees,
not 0 degrees, but 180 degrees.
And now, when we
change the detuning,
the effective
magnetic field tilts,
but the spin keeps on
precessing at 180 degrees
and eventually when we
sweep through the resonance,
the effective magnetic field at
low frequency of the rotating
field becomes the real
magnetic field is now
pointing in the z
direction and the spin
has followed the
180 degree rotation.
So in other words,
it does not matter
whether you go from low to high
or from high to low frequency.
Whenever you go through the
resonance, you flip the spin.
Let's close that Let's see.
It is that.
So the more
generalized answer is
that the rapid adiabatic passage
always swaps the spin state
no matter which way you sweep.
When you start in spin up,
you wind up in spin down.
When you start in
spin down, you wind up
in spin up because
what you're doing
is you're inverting
the direction
of the effective magnetic field
and the spin just follows.
So therefore it goes both ways.
It applies to-- you can
say to the ground state
with the lowest energy state,
it applies to the highest energy
state, and as such,
it is actually
a swap operation like
the pi over 2 pulse.
When you have a pi over
2 pulse, you have a spin
and you just pulse on a
rotating magnetic field, which
in the rotating flame
means you have an x field.
When the spin was up at the
Rabi frequency, rotates down.
When the spin was down at the
Rabi frequency, it rotates up.
And quantum mechanically it just
means you take the population
in two states and your
unitary time evolution
is a swap operation.
And the classical counterpart
is what we just discussed,
the rapid adiabatic passage.
However, there is one big
experimental advantage
of doing rapid adiabatic
passage over pi over 2 pulse.
And I think many of you
use rapid adiabatic passage
in the lab.
Remember, if you give
yourself the drop,
you want to transfer the
magnetic moment form spin up
to spin down.
If you want to do it
with the pi pulse--
if you want to do it with
the-- I said pi over 2 pulse,
I meant pi pulse.
The only way how
with a pulse you
can rotate the magnetic
moment by 180 degrees, if you
are exactly on resonance, where
the fictitious field cancels
the static field and what you
have is in the rotating frame
is only a field in x.
And then you can rotate
around the x-axis.
But if for some reason you're
not exactly on resonance, then
the fictitious field does
not cancel the static field,
and your effective magnetic
field is at an angle.
And if you rotate an
effective magnetic field,
which is not in the
x-axis but at an angle,
you cannot do a full inversion
of the magnetic moment.
So in other words, if you want
to use a pi pulse to flip over
a spin, you have to pulse
on your drive exactly
on resonance.
And if you have MBN magnetic
fields which drift by a few
milligals and you're not
sure where the resonance is,
you cannot do a
perfect pi pulse.
But with the sweep, you just
have to sweep from point A
to point B, and if you know
you cross the resonance,
you have a perfect inversion
of the magnetic moment, which
is robust against
frequency drifts.
Of course, you have
to do a longer sweep.
The pi pulse is the
shortest possible wave.
If you heat the cloud on
resonance, you first sweep,
nothing happens,
and you go through resonance and
just view further and further,
you waste some of your time.
So you pay a price for it,
but often we want precision
and we have the time
to do it and then
the job is done by
rapid adiabatic passage.
Let me just mention one
more thing and then I stop.
I have discussed the
physics of keeping--
with rapid adiabatic
passage, I've
discussed with you the physics
that rapid precession keeps
a magnetic moment aligned with
an effective magnetic field.
Let me now discuss
the same phenomenon
but in a very
different environment.
And this is a similar process
happen in a magnetic trap.
In a magnetic trap, we
don't have any drive
or we have a
time-dependent field.
But what happens is, we
have a magnetic field,
but the atoms move
through the atom trap.
So the atom sees a
changing magnetic field.
And in many of our
experiments here at MIT,
we use a quadrupolar field.
We've discussed some of
these aspects in 8.422,
so a quadrupolar
field, the field
has to be homogeneous in order
to provide trapping forces,
so we often use quadrupolar
fields, a lot of advantages.
That's how we build the
tightest magnetic traps.
But what happens now
is, if an atom moves
along this projector, it
moves up in the laboratory,
here t let's say the
atom is in spin up.
Here it's now a aligned.
The magnetic field is
opposite to the spin
and now it moves up, and now
the magnetic field up here
is pointing up.
The physics I explain to you
rapid adiabatic passage means
that the rapid
precession off this spin
means that as the atom
moves, the spin stays
aligned with the magnetic field.
So you find the
same physics here
in a different environment, but
the mathematical description
is the same.
Of course, and that's my
last comment for today,
if you have a spheric
quadrupole trap
and you go right
through the origin,
you're out of luck
because here, the atom
sees the magnetic field is down.
It gets smaller,
the magnetic field
gets smaller, gets smaller.
The magnet field gets zero.
Oopsy, the magnetic field
points in the other direction.
And there was no warning.
The magnetic field has jumped
from 0 degree to 180 degree.
There was never, ever any
transverse field around which
the atom could precess and
change its orientation.
So therefore, when an atom is
aligned with a magnetic field
moves through the origin,
oopsy, it's anti aligned.
It has lost its orientation with
respect to the magnetic field,
and this is the breakdown
of rapid adiabatic passage
because there's no adiabadicity.
It is not an adiabatic
change of the direction
of the magnetic field,
it's a sudden field.
And the consequences are bad.
You lose your atoms
from the magnetic trap.
It's called Majorana losses.
A lot of people know
what I'm talking about,
but I'm not explaining
it in detail.
Time is over.
Any question about
what I've discussed?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You said
the weights of the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I would say-- the
question is about the frequency
weights and if you switch
on the frequency drive,
it's not a delta function.
If we are far away
from resonance,
it doesn't really matter.
That is, of course, a criterion
that the effective weights
of the frequency should not
be comparable to the detuning.
So then you switch it on,
but you're so far away
from resonance that
it doesn't matter
if you have a small weights,
the effective detuning is still
large.
You scan for resonance.
But these are sort of
the boundary condition.
The exact solution in
the Landau-Zener problem,
for instance, assumes you
go from minus infinity
to plus infinity
in the detuning.
Nobody does that.
So we're discussing sort of
sweep finite duration effects,
but usually we are pretty close
to the idealized assumption.
OK, enjoy the Monday holiday.
We meet on Tuesday,
and Tuesday is
in building 37 in our
standard classroom.